Çeviri: Esra Çakmak
Gözden geçirme: Figen Ergürbüz
Ağaca tırmanan balık mısınız?
Bu soruyu en sonunda
tekrar soracağım ben size.
Ben 3 tane projesi reddedilmiş,
bir tanesi bıçak sırtından dönmüş,
okulu gereğinden çok uzatmış;
bir buçuk sene öncesine kadar,
"Aman Işıl'ın bir oğlu var,
sakın öyle olma."
diye ibret gösterilen biri olarak
bugün karşınızdayım.
Aranızda "Fırsat verilse neler yaparım!"
diyen var mı?
Süper, başka?
Arkadaşlar,
kimse size fırsat vermeyecek.
Hatta sizi tutup aşağı çekmeye
çalışacaklar
ve bunlar da en yakınlarınız olacak.
Alice Harikalar Diyarında'yı
bilir misiniz?
Çok güzel bir bölüm vardır orada;
Alice koşar koşar koşar,
bir yol ayrımına gelir.
Sağdan mı gitsin,
soldan mı gitsin?
Karar veremez.
Kafayı bir kaldırır
-o bizim o meşhur kedi var ya
sürekli kaybolup geri gelen,
sinir bozucu, manyak bir şey-
onunla karşılaşır
ve çok güzel bir soru sorar ona:
Nereden gitmeliyim?
Kedinin verdiği cevap muazzamdır:
Nereye gideceğini bilmiyorsan,
hangi yoldan gideceğinin
bir önemi yoktur.
Türkiye, nereye gideceğini bilmeyen
Alice'lerle dolu.
Bence bir gencin hayali,
sadece üniversiteyi bitirip
bir yerde çalışmak olmamalı.
Kendi hayallerinin
peşinden koşmak olmalı.
Şimdi siz diyorsunuzdur;
adamın teki çıktı
işte Alice dedi,
ağaç dedi, kedi dedi hani
kim bu ya, diye.
Ben öncelikle kısaca kendimi tanıtayım.
Ne yaptığımı anlatıp
bu süreçte neler yaşadığımla
bağlayayım istiyorum.
Benim adım Kerem Deveci.
Enlil Projesi'nin kurucusuyum.
Ben de ağaca çıkmaya çalışan
bir balıktım aslında.
Sonrasında Smart City'ler için
enerji konseptinde bir proje geliştirdim.
Smart City ne, derseniz
kısaca şöyle açıklayayım:
İskoçyalı bilim adamı James Watt'ın
sanayi devrimini başlatmasıyla
nüfuslarımızda
inanılmaz bir patlama yaşandı
ve günümüz teknolojisinin entegrasyonuyla
bu sorunlara biz çözüm buluyorsak,
buna Smart City diyoruz.
Bir fikrin nereden çıkacağını
bilemezsiniz.
William diye bir abimiz var.
Bu bir gün bir arkadaşını
ziyarete gidiyor.
Arkadaşının domuz kesimhanesi var.
Yani hayvan bir yerden giriyor;
işçilerin sadece bir bölümü
derisini kesiyor,
sadece başka bir bölümü
organlarını ayıklıyor.
İşçilerin sadece başka bir bölümü ise
etleri kesiyor.
Yani seri üretim et kesim tesisi.
William'ın kafada şimşekler çakıyor.
"Bunu patronuma anlatmam lazım,
aynısını bizim yapmamız lazım," diyor
ve gidiyor.
Patron bu fikre bayılıyor
ve patronu Henry Ford,
dünyanın ilk seri üretim araç fabrikasını
kurarak modern dünyayı oluşturuyor.
Tamamıyla alakasız bir sektörün,
tamamıyla alakasız başka bir sektörü
etkileyerek
modern dünyayı oluşturmasının
en güzel örneğidir.
Sadece fikir
sizi hiçbir yere getirmez.
Diferansiyel Denklemler dersini bilen
veya üniversitede almış olan var mıdır?
Çoğumuz ikinci seferde verir
hatta bu dersi.
Ki onlar belli oluyor burada.
Sir Isaac Newton'ın bulduğu
bir yöntemdir bu.
Ama işin ilginç tarafı
aynı dönemde,
aynı yıllarda Almanya'da
Leibniz diye biri daha buluyor.
Yani biz anlatılırken anlamıyoruz,
adamlar buluyor.
Yani fikir ne kadar karmaşık olursa olsun,
bulunabilir.
Fikrim var diye oturmayın,
harekete geçin.
En önemlisi ise cesarettir.
Karl Benz adında muazzam bir
Alman mühendis var.
Bu adamcağız dünyanın ilk otomobilini
kendi garajında yapıyor.
Ama zamanın Alman imparatoru,
atları çok sevdiği için
bu fikre sıcak bakmıyor
ve izin vermiyor.
Karısı Bertha Benz,
tabiri caizse
arabayı alıp kaçırıyor
ve kız kardeşini ziyarete gidiyor.
Ertesi gün,
bütün Almanya bu kadını konuşuyor.
Düşünsenize;
araba diye bir kavram yok,
kadının teki bir şeye binmiş,
pır pır pır bir yere gidiyor.
Hani şimdi sokağa çıkıp
UFO görmeniz gibi bir şey
ve Alman imparatoru
izin vermek zorunda kalıyor.
Bu kadının cesareti sayesinde
Mercedes Benz
gibi bir imparatorluk doğuyor.
Yani fikir,
harekete geçmek ve cesaret.
Benim hikâyemin başladığı yere gelirsek...
Metrobüs hattında seyahat ederken
tahliye kapakçıklarının
hareket ettiğini gördüm.
Dedim, ben bu rüzgarı kullanırım.
Hemen patent dosyası nasıl yazılıyor,
onu öğrendim ve aldım.
Tabi bu sürede fikrimi anlatıyorum;
şöyle fikrim var,
böyle fikrim var,
işte onu yapacağız,
bunu yapacağız diye.
Çok güzel geri dönüşler aldım:
"Oğlum, boş boş işlerle uğraşma."
(Kahkaha)
"Oğlum, gir bir işe çalış."
Gidiyorum işte üniversitedeki
hocama anlatıyorum,
"Sat, sat, sat, sat.
Oğlum bunu sana yaptırmazlar.
Bul birini, direkt sat."
İşte arkadaşlarıma gidip anlatıyorum,
"Ya Keremcim keyfimize bakalım,
boşver sonra konuşuruz," diyorlar.
Böyle muazzam motivasyon sözcükleri
havalarda uçuşuyor.
İnat ettim, aleti ürettim.
Ürettim derken,
odamda ürettim.
Tabi bu sefer evdekiler de
birazcık ses etmeye başladı.
Sonuç olarak salonun ortasında
2-2.5 metrelik bir alet,
hoş bir manzara değildi.
Bir kuluçka programına başvuruda bulundum,
kabul edildim.
İnanılmaz mutluyum ama.
İlk defa,
dolaylı yoldan da olsa,
projem onaylanmıştı.
"Ya aslında fena fikir de değilmiş,"
denmeye de başlanmıştı.
Bu süreçten sonra, melek yatırımcılarla
görüşmeye başladım.
Şimdi melek yatırımcılarla görüşünce,
şöyle bir diyalog geçmeye başladı:
"Sen kimsin ya
belediyeye gireceksin?"
"Ya sen kimsin bunu yapacaksın?"
"Ya projemiz olacağını düşünmüyoruz."
"Yani çok da böyle bir insanların
dikkatini çekeceğini düşünmüyoruz.
Çalışmaz bu,"
deyip dalga geçip yolladılar beni.
Sonra başka melek yatırımcılar çağırdı,
onlar da dalga geçip yolladılar beni.
Bir ara şeyi düşündüm,
herhâlde kendi aralarında
eğlence gibi bir şey olmuştum.
Hani çağırıp eğlenip
yolluyorlardı beni.
Sonra hibe verecek kuruluşlarla
görüşmeye başladım.
Bunlar daha yaratıcı ama.
"Ya biz bunu koyarız,
ama bunu çalarlar."
Çalardan kastı, alıp götürürler.
Veya şey var,
"Ya tamam biz bunu koyarız,
ama adam gelir elini içine sokar."
Yani daha neler neler duydum
ve tahmin ettiğiniz gibi
yatırım da alamadım.
Yatırım alamayınca,
kuluçka sürecinden de elendim.
En dipteydim artık.
Yapacak hiçbir şey yoktu.
Bütün kapılar suratıma kapanmış
ve projem de
çöp olmaya doğru gidiyordu.
Bertha Benz'i hatırladınız mı?
Daha önce işe yaradıysa,
tekrar yaramalıydı.
İnsanlara anlatmakla olmuyordu,
onu göstermem lazımdı.
Direkt belediyeyi aradım,
dedim benim böyle bir fikrim var.
İnanılmaz yardımcı oldular
ve Enlil Projesi'ni
test için yerleştirdik.
Sonra çok enteresan bir şey oldu.
Projemi sosyal hesaplardan
paylaşmaya başladım.
Bir anda yabancılar paylaşmaya başladı.
Yabancılar paylaşınca,
Türkler paylaşmaya başladı.
Türkler paylaşınca,
yine yabancılar paylaşmaya başladı.
Böyle çığ gibi büyüdü.
İşte Cedar,
World Economic Forum,
Forbes, 9GAG,
işte BBC News...
Aklınıza hangi kanal geliyorsa,
Japonya'dan tutun da
Hindistan'a kadar.
Silikon Vadisi'nde
referans verilmeye başlandı.
Brown Üniversitesi'nde
ve çeşitli avrupa üniversitelerinde
derslerde anlatılmaya başlandı.
Her gün 150-200 tane
mail almaya başladım.
Hatta 250.
Tek bir ülke hariç tabii.
Bu süreçten sonra,
bu benimle dalga geçen yatırımcılar
geri aramaya başladılar.
"Keremcim görüşemiyoruz,
bir çay içelim, kahve içelim.
Yatırım konuşalım."
Bu ayarda.
Onlara söylediğim tek bir şey vardı:
"Ben daha vizyonel insanlarla
çalışmak istiyorum, güle güle."
Ben birazcık daha
idealist olma taraftarıyım.
Çünkü bana inanmayan
veya benim inanmadığım birinden
yatırım almaktansa,
inandığım yolda batmayı tercih ederim.
Mercedes Benz Türk Start-Up yarışmasında
teknoloji alanında
birincilik ödülü aldık.
Akabinde İskoçya'da
dünyanın en büyük iklim yarışması,
ki 44 farklı ülkeden gelen yarışmacıların
olduğu bir yarışma bu,
orada da birincilik ödülü aldık.
Mercedes'in taktiğiyle
ortaya çıkan bir ürünün
Mercedes'ten ödül alması
ve modern şehirleri oluşturan
James Watt'ın memleketi İskoçya'da
geleceğin şehirleri konusunda ödül almamız
çok güzel bir tesadüf oldu bizim için.
Bu süreçten sonra şöyle de
bir şey başladı ama,
"Ya kesin bir yerde dayısı var ya,
torpilsiz bu iş hayatta olmaz!" diye.
Bunlardan ne yazık ki kurtulamıyoruz.
Türkiye, bizim gibi girişimciler için
çok zor bir yer.
İnanılmaz zor bir ortam.
Yabancılar yapmadıysa
veya yapamadıysa
bizim ne haddimize, anlayışı var.
Veya daha kötüsü,
tüccar zihniyeti var
ve tüccar zihniyetiyle
teknoloji geliştirilemez.
Allah aşkına
büyük firmalarımıza bir bakın,
kaç tanesi yüksek teknoloji ürünü
üretiyor ki?
Ya bu ayıp bizim mi?
Değil.
Ama bunu düzeltmekle yükümlü
olan nesil biziz.
Belki bizden sonrakilerin
böyle bir şansı da olmayacak.
Kaygı, geleceğe duyulan korkudur.
Geleceğe korku duyarken
bugünü nasıl yaşayacaksınız?
Başarısız olma korkusu ile
yetiştiriliyoruz
veya para odaklı başarı,
iliklerimize kadar işliyor.
Belli yollardan gidersen başarılı olursun
veya yenilik çıkartırsın anlayışı,
gençliği zehirliyor.
Toplumun size ördüğü duvarlarda
yaşayacağım diye
potansiyelinizi öldürmeyin.
Başarısızlığınızı sevin,
anlatmaktan da çekinmeyin.
Çünkü ne kadar çok başarısız olursanız,
kendinizi o kadar iyi tanırsınız
ve çok daha güçlü ayağa kalkarsınız.
Bırakın, sizinle dalga geçsinler.
Bırakın, sizi aşağı çekmeye çalışsınlar.
Bırakın, sizi ciddiye almasınlar
ve hatta bırakın,
size aptal desinler.
Unutmayın,
fikirleriyle dalga geçilenler
dünyayı kurmuştur.
Fikrinizden vazgeçmeyin.
Sizin gördüklerinizi
başkalarının görmüyor olması,
onun var olmadığı anlamına gelmez.
Sadece, onların göremediği
anlamına gelir.
Siz inandıysanız
o iş olmuştur.
Kimse hayatta lineer olarak
yükselemez zaten.
Çıkacaksınız,
ineceksiniz,
yükseleceksiniz,
en dibe vuracaksınız;
ama günün sonunda neredesiniz,
önemli olan o.
Yelkenciler
yarış esnasında durmazlar.
Sağa giderler,
sola giderler,
zikzak çizerler,
daireler çizerler
ve hatta geri giderler.
Çünkü durdukları zaman,
bir daha harekete geçemezler.
Yelkenciler gibi olmak lazım.
Dibe vurmaktan korkmayın.
Rüzgar sizi illa ki ileri taşıyacaktır.
Bizim çok güzel değerlerimiz var aslında.
Canan Dağdeviren'ler,
Oktay Sinanoğul'ları,
Aziz Sancar'lar
ve daha niceleri...
Bu insanlar ne yapmış,
bu insanlar ne yapıyor?
Bu insanların öğütlerini dinlemek lazım.
Ama zaten en güzel öğüdü
Mustafa Kemal Atatürk bize vermiş.
Fikriniz hür, vicdanınız hür,
irfanınız hür olsun.
Gerisi bir şekilde geliyor zaten.
Balık-ağaç olayına gelirsek...
Albert Einstein'ın
çok güzel bir lafı vardır:
"Aslında herkes dahidir,
ama siz bir balığı, ağaca tırmanma
yeteneğine göre yargılarsanız
balık hayatı boyunca
aptal olduğunu düşünerek geçirecektir."
Şimdi baştaki soruyu değiştirerek
ben size sorayım.
Hâlâ inatla ağaca tırmanmaya çalışan
balık mı olmak istiyorsunuz,
yoksa potansiyelinizi fark edip
sonsuz okyanusu
keşfetmeye çalışan balık mı?
Karar sizin, teşekkürler.
(Alkış)